let's go to our caller from the three
six one area code who's calling today
from 361 hello yes who's this this is
Kyle from Texas hey Kyle I just wanted
to say happy birthday or belated
birthday and I think I are your
objectivity and your work it's really
great I watched a trump State of the
Union last night and it was a very
interesting not not a very great thing
at all he said something about a he's
talking about the true Venezuelan
president or something like that yeah at
some point and that really did worry me
I wondered how this how this could
affect a decade and this was you know
another like instance of u.s.
interventionism or was trying trying to
do something with this or what do you
think you know it's struck so first of
all as I've said before I do not think
highly of Nicolas Maduro I think he's
terrible
I think he's raped and pillaged the
resources of Venezuela for his own gain
and he's completely corrupt but I I
can't have his replacement be selected
by the United States or the CIA or
whatever right so you can hold both of
you simultaneously yeah
the second that Donald Trump said Hwang
guai though is the rightful president of
Venezuela and we are completely behind
him and Democrats and Republicans both
started cheering that is the work of
American intervention you know and and
when you ask me why did he do it I feel
like it's similar to when he says we
will never be a socialist country it's
just sort of it's it's red meat that may
or may not relate to real policy but
it's absolutely disastrous and I cringed
when he did that do you think that on
again like Nicolas Maduro or any of you
know people that are involved with and
would see this and like maybe you know
say something to him and how do you
think he would react well I don't think
that Nicolas Maduro is going to be
having any conversation saying would
they say something to Trump or to gly
though no it's you know say someone who
worked for Nicolas you know would watch
this or something
like that you know who keeps up with you
know world politics or something just
you know and then you know sees you know
him saying something about you know the
true president we have Venezuela do you
think that this could cause a very um
passionate response
I don't know and of course you know the
Trump administration doesn't have
diplomatic relations with the Maduro
administration's yeah I don't I don't
really think that that's the issue I
think it's more just it's yet again you
know at least pretend like you're not
meddling but once you publicly say this
guy is the rightful president of
Venezuela then if that ends up becoming
the reality in Venezuela it is
understandably going to be seen as US
intervention in the United States
picking who they want and that's the
last thing another Latin American
country needs exactly yeah
all right well that answers my question
thank you having all right appreciate
the phone call thank you so much that
does it for today sorry I was not able
to get to everybody who called in some
great calls and we will take calls again
quick break back after this